MAYA ANGELOU ONCE SAID, "EACH
ONE OF US HAS LIVED THROUGH SOME
DEVASTATION, SOME LONELINESS,
SOME WEATHER SUPERSTORM
OR SPIRITUAL SUPERSTORM.
WHEN WE LOOK AT EACH OTHER WE
MUST SAY, I UNDERSTAND.
I UNDERSTAND HOW YOU
FEEL, BECAUSE I HAVE BEEN
THERE MYSELF.”
MY GREAT FRIEND, FILMMAKER, AND
PHILANTHROPIST, TYLER PERRY,
PERSONIFIES EMPATHY.
TYLER KNOWS WHAT IT IS TO BE
HUNGRY, TO BE WITHOUT A HOME,
TO FEEL UNSAFE AND UNCERTAIN.
SO WHEN HE BUYS GROCERIES FOR
1,000 OF HIS NEIGHBORS, SUPPORTS
A WOMEN'S SHELTER, OR QUIETLY
PAYS TUITION FOR A HARD-WORKING
STUDENT, TYLER IS COMING FROM A
PLACE OF SHARED EXPERIENCE.
TYLER PAID FOR THE FUNERALS OF
THE BLACK MEN WHOSE NAMES WERE
ON THE PLACARDS AT MARCHES.
IN ATLANTA, WHERE HIS FILM
STUDIOS EMPLOY THOUSANDS,
HE CREATED CAMP QUARANTINE,
MAKING IT POSSIBLE
TO SAFELY CONTINUE
MAKING A LIVING.
EVERYONE IN TYLER'S CAMP
HAS BEEN GIVEN
ACCESS TO THE VACCINE.
AND THIS WAS JUST
IN THE PAST YEAR.
>> THE MOST GENEROUS PERSON
THAT I KNEW GROWING UP
WAS CLEARLY MY MOTHER.
SHE TAUGHT ME TO NEVER LOOK FOR
SOMEBODY ELSE TO BE THE HERO
AND NEVER SIT AROUND
WAITING FOR CHARIOTS
FIND A WAY.
SHE WOULD SAY,
JUNIOR, YOU FIND A WAY.
IN THAT FINDING A WAY, SHE WOULD
ALWAYS ENCOURAGE ME
TO HELP SOMEONE ELSE.
I REMEMBER GETTING OUT OF BED,
AND LITERALLY STEPPING ON
SOMEONE ON THE FLOOR.
AND I GO IN THE KITCHEN AND I'M LIKE,
"WHO ARE THESE PEOPLE?"
AND SHE LIKE,
"SHH, THEY NEEDED A
PLACE TO STAY."
SHE DIDN'T HAVE MUCH,
BUT WHATEVER SHE HAD
SHE WAS WILLING TO SHARE.
SO, THAT'S VERY MUCH IN MY DNA.
>> IT IS HOW HE WAS RAISED.
THAT IF SOMEBODY REACHES
OUT, THEN YOU REACH OUT
TO SOMEBODY ELSE, AND
THEN THEY'LL REACH
OUT TO SOMEBODY ELSE.
>> WHEN COVID HIT, IT WAS
REALLY IMPORTANT FOR ME TO
GET EVERYBODY BACK TO WORK.
I'M ALWAYS THE PERSON
THAT SAYS OKAY, THIS IS
HAPPENING, WHAT DO
WE DO TO FIX IT?
HOW DO WE FIGHT IT?
>> HE FED ALL THESE PEOPLE
DURING THE PANDEMIC.
HE MADE SURE PEOPLE HAD WHAT
THEY NEEDED TO GET THROUGH IT.
>> THE PERRY FOUNDATION
HAS BEEN ABOUT TRANSFERRING
TRAGEDY INTO TRIUMPH.
I DON'T WANT TO HAVE A FOUNDATION
THAT IS TARGETED AT ONE
SPECIFIC THING, BECAUSE
THE NEED IS SO GREAT
ALL OVER MANY THINGS.
BATTERED WOMEN, TRAFFICKED
CHILDREN, POVERTY,
HOMELESSNESS, ADDICTION,
WHATEVER WE CAN DO,
WHEREVER WE CAN SHOW
UP TO HELP.
>> THERE'S NO HARM IN CARING.
HE'S GOING TO CREATE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR OTHER PEOPLE,
LIKE OPPORTUNITIES
WERE CREATED FOR HIM.
HE'S GOING TO ENCOURAGE
OTHER PEOPLE,
THE WAY PEOPLE
ENCOURAGED HIM.
>> WHEN YOU'VE BEEN GIVEN A
VOICE, THERE'S A HUGE
RESPONSIBILITY TO USE IT IN A
WAY THAT SUSTAINS CHANGE.
>> SO, HE CREATED A LIVING LEGACY
THAT KEEPS ON GIVING.
WHAT'S BETTER THAN THAT?
THIS MAN EXEMPLIFIES THE BEST
YOU COULD ASK FROM ANY HUMAN
AND THAT IS TO CARE ABOUT
YOUR FELLOW HUMAN BEINGS.
>> IT GOES BACK TO MY MOTHER,
JUNIOR, FIND A WAY.
FIND A WAY.
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
>> TYLER, I KNOW YOU NEVER DO
WHAT YOU DO FOR THANKS, BUT I AM
GRATEFUL FOR THE COUNTLESS
WAYS YOU WORK TO
MAKE OURS A BETTER WORLD.
IT IS MY HONOR TO PRESENT TO YOU
THE JEAN HERSHOLT
HUMANITARIAN AWARD.
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU,
THAT IS, THAT’S INCREDIBLY KIND.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THEY ONLY GAVE ME
A FEW MINUTES,
SO I WANNA SAY A
VERY SPECIAL THANKS
TO MISS VIOLA DAVIS,
WHO IS NOMINATED TONIGHT
AND DOING THIS.
THANK YOU, THANK YOU,
I REALLY APPRECIATE IT.
TO THE BOARD OF GOVERNORS,
ESPECIALLY TO WHOOPI
GOLDBERG, AVA.
YOU KNOW WHEN I SET OUT
TO HELP SOMEONE,
IT IS MY INTENTION TO
DO JUST THAT.
I’M NOT TRYING TO DO ANYTHING
OTHER THAN MEET SOMEBODY
AT THEIR HUMANITY.
LIKE, CASE IN POINT,
THIS ONE TIME I REMEMBER I WAS,
MAYBE IT WAS ABOUT
17 YEARS AGO.
I RENTED THIS BUILDING
AND WE WERE
USING IT FOR PRODUCTION
AND I WAS WALKING TO MY
CAR ONE DAY AND I SEE THIS
WOMAN COMING UP OUT
OF THE CORNER OF MY EYE
AND I SAY, SHE’S HOMELESS,
LET ME GIVE HER SOME MONEY.
JUDGMENT.
I WISH I HAD TIME
TO TALK ABOUT JUDGMENT.
ANYWAY, I REACH IN MY POCKET
AND I’M ABOUT TO GIVE
HER THE MONEY.
SHE SAYS, “EXCUSE ME SIR.
DO YOU HAVE ANY SHOES?”
IT STOPPED ME COLD BECAUSE
I REMEMBER BEING HOMELESS
AND HAVING ONE PAIR OF SHOES
AND THEY WERE BENT OVER
AT THE HEELS.
SO I WAS LIKE, YEAH.
SO I TOOK HER INTO THE STUDIO.
SHE WAS HESITANT TO GO IN,
BUT WE WENT IN.
WE GO TO WARDROBE AND
THERE ARE ALL THESE BOXES AND
EVERYTHING AROUND THE WALLS
AND FABRICS AND RACKS OF CLOTHES.
SO WE ENDED UP HAVING TO
STAND IN THE MIDDLE OF THE FLOOR.
SO AS WE’RE STANDING THERE
IN WARDROBE, WE FIND HER SOME SHOES,
WE HELP HER PUT THEM ON.
I STAND UP, I’M WAITING FOR HER
TO LOOK UP AND ALL THIS TIME
SHE’S LOOKING DOWN.
SHE FINALLY LOOKS UP.
SHE’S GOT TEARS IN HER EYES.
SHE SAID, “THANK YOU, JESUS,
MY FEET ARE OFF THE GROUND.”
IN THAT MOMENT I JUST RECALL HER
SAYING TO ME, “I THOUGHT
YOU WOULD HATE ME FOR ASKING.”
I’M LIKE HOW CAN I HATE YOU
WHEN I USED TO BE YOU?
HOW CAN I HATE YOU WHEN
I HAD A MOTHER WHO
GREW UP IN A JIM CROW SOUTH
IN LOUISIANA, RURAL LOUISIANA
RIGHT ACROSS THE BORDER
FROM MISSISSIPPI,
WHO AT 9 OR 10 YEARS OLD
WAS GRIEVING THE DEATH OF
EMMETT TILL.
AS SHE GOT
A LITTLE BIT OLDER.
SHE WAS GRIEVING THE
DEATH OF THE CIVIL RIGHTS BOYS
AND THE LITTLE GIRLS WHO
WERE IN THE BOMBING IN ALABAMA.
SHE GRIEVED ALL THIS, ALL
THESE YEARS AND I REMEMBER
BEING A LITTLE BOY
AND COMING HOME,
AND SHE WAS AT HOME BEING LIKE
WHAT ARE YOU DOING HOME?
YOU'RE SUPPOSED TO
BE AT WORK.
SHE WAS IN TEARS THAT DAY.
SHE SAID THERE WAS A BOMB
THREAT AND SHE COULDN'T
BELIEVE THAT SOMEONE WANTED
TO BLOW UP THIS PLACE
WHERE SHE WORKED.
WHERE SHE TOOK CARE
OF ALL THESE TODDLERS.
IT WAS THE JEWISH
COMMUNITY CENTER.
MY MOTHER TAUGHT ME TO
REFUSE HATE.
SHE TAUGHT ME TO REFUSE
BLANKET JUDGMENT,
AND IN THIS TIME, AND WITH
ALL OF THE INTERNET AND
SOCIAL MEDIA AND ALGORITHMS
AND EVERYTHING THAT WANTS
US TO THINK A CERTAIN WAY,
THE 24-HOUR NEWS CYCLE,
IT IS MY HOPE THAT ALL OF US
WOULD TEACH OUR KIDS
AND I WANT TO REMEMBER,
JUST REFUSE HATE.
DON’T HATE ANYBODY.
I REFUSE TO HATE SOMEONE
BECAUSE THEY ARE MEXICAN
OR BECAUSE THEY ARE BLACK
OR WHITE OR LGBTQ.
I REFUSE TO HATE SOMEONE
BECAUSE THEY ARE
A POLICE OFFICER.
I REFUSE TO HATE SOMEONE
BECAUSE THEY ARE ASIAN.
I WOULD HOPE THAT WE WOULD
REFUSE HATE AND I WANT TO
TAKE THIS JEAN HERSHOLT
HUMANITARIAN AWARD
AND DEDICATE IT TO ANYONE
WHO WANTS TO STAND
IN THE MIDDLE, NO MATTER
WHAT’S AROUND THE WALL.
STAND IN THE MIDDLE ’CAUSE
THAT’S WHERE HEALING HAPPENS.
THAT’S WHERE CONVERSATION
HAPPENS.
THAT’S WHERE CHANGE HAPPENS.
IT HAPPENS IN
THE MIDDLE.
SO ANYONE WHO
WANTS TO MEET ME IN
THE MIDDLE, TO REFUSE HATE,
TO REFUSE BLANKET JUDGMENT,
AND TO HELP LIFT SOMEONE’S
FEET OFF THE GROUND,
THIS ONE IS FOR YOU TOO.
GOD BLESS YOU AND
THANK YOU ACADEMY.
I APPRECIATE IT.
THANK YOU.